Speaker 1: Let's go. So many
different folks wanting to chat today.
Let's go next to Glenn from
Virginia. Glenn, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you just fine.
Speaker 4: OK, great, this is my first time
calling. Thanks for taking the call. Pleasure,
Mike. My question for you is with respect to
voting rights, just to give you context. I am
an African-American in my mid-forties and I fear
that there will likely be no meaningful voting
rights legislation coming down the pipeline. So
my question for you is, do you think the Democrats
mischaracterized? Well, let me rephrase.
Instead of saying, mischaracterize,
do you think that they did a poor job
in messaging as you know so much with
respect to legislation comes down to
messaging? And what I mean by that
is with voting rights legislation, do you
think the Democrats would have done themselves
more of a service if they sold it as an issue
for the less powerful, the less connected
those who are in perhaps rural areas and having
access to voting as opposed to selling it more of
a race issue with respect to black and brown
people. Do you think the Democrats sort of
fumbled the football, so to speak, in that regard?
Speaker 1: It's always hard to go back
and say what what might have been, but it's a
good question, which is if the framing along
defending voting rights and pushing back against
all of these wacky right wing bills had been
they are going after the little guy rather than
they are targeting disproportionately nonwhite
minorities. Would it have been better received?
Speaker 2: Here's the thing
Speaker 1: for the people on the left
who understand the issue, they're already
Speaker 2: behind supporting
Speaker 1: voting rights in a real way
and fighting back against what Republicans
Speaker 2: are doing. And if the
Speaker 1: left had framed it in the way
you suggest the right is still going to be
just as against it, and they would come up
with some way to justify it. And so then it
just becomes a fight of like, do they do
it effectively or not? I just don't know.
Speaker 2: They're sometimes one of the prop.
Speaker 1: One of the mistakes we make is we say,
Hey, you know what? Here's the talking point they
came up with. And that talking point was so easily
defeated. Here's a different talking point that
would have been much better. But what you have
to remember is if the talking point had been
different, their response also would have been
different. And so I just don't know, because
fundamentally Republican elected officials
know that they need all of these different
voter suppression tactics in order to win,
and they were going to justify them one way
or the other. So it's hard for me to say
that it would have been much more successfully
Speaker 2: argued
Speaker 1: if they argued along class
rather than race lines. And to be honest,
they did also argue it along class lines
because often it's about poor areas,
not nonwhite areas.
Speaker 4:
Yeah, I agree. I just look back at some of the
tactics of the Obama administration, especially
in the 2012 campaign. They sort of anticipated
the backlash, so to speak, and they were much more
nimble and making the class warfare argument.
And even if the Republican attempts are based on
racial sensitivities, I just think you
do yourself a lot more of a service if
you make the class warfare argument.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm not disagreeing
with you. My only caveat
Speaker 2: would be, I think the
Speaker 1: Republican Party would have been ready
for that as well, but I don't think you're wrong.
OK, fair enough. Thanks for my call. All
right, thanks, Glenn. There is Glenn.
Very, very important topic. I mean, a
great great great question to be asking.